un réfrigérateur en pleine nature ou
plutôt dans le stationnement d'un musée
rempli de plats gratuit c'est inhabituel
talibans auteurs bridge 45 ans vient s'y
servir régulièrement depuis la pandémie
tupi qu'elle a perdu son travail et son
logement
oh ça c'est délicieux dit il faut que
vous l'essayez je suis sans abri depuis
45 jours dit il mais ma santé est bonne
je suis végétarien et je cours beaucoup
ce plat végétarien a été concocté par le
restaurant callas tacos au total 1400
repas préparés depuis décembre
pour les 26 frigo éparpillés à travers
la ville
nous livrons 130 repas aujourd'hui 10
bettina stone qu'à washington ne va pas
si bien
elle a beau être la capitale de la
première puissance mondiale
plus de cent trente mille personnes ne
mangent pas à leur faim un scandale pour
le restaurateur marque buell qui a
décidé d'agir tout en aidant les
restaurants qui ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires chuter
c'était une question de vie ou de mort
dit il
il crée fit de fred est fait d'une
pierre deux coups
aider les restaurants et nourrir ceux
qui ont faim besser
sa règle la fin d'août il parce qu'on
offre un plat aux gens tous les jours
s'est ouvert ses dehors accessible à
tous dit il
on ne pose pas de questions abattoirs
quant au restaurant ils reçoivent 6 $
pour chaque repas préparé une offre open
c'est assez pour qu'ils restent ouverts
du tour payer les employés et garder la
tête hors dom ses six premiers
réfrigérateur lui sont donnés par
l'équipe de base-ball et washington
nationals anciennement expos de montréal
puis grâce à plusieurs levée de fonds il
parvient payer les restaurateurs et
d'autres réfrigérateur les menus sont
variées y en a pour tous les goûts
visitez bien saignant à une salade
jardinières le principe est de fournir
des plats nutritifs ivan ivanov fait
partie des livreurs bénévoles
et remplit les frigos chaque matin
depuis quatre mois avant de se rendre à
son travail
au menu de la lasagne aujourd'hui c'est
l'inauguration d'un nouveau frigo dans
la cour d'un centre communautaire à
takoma park en banlieue de washington 10
% de notre population ne sait pas où
trouver à manger dit cet élu du comté
beaucoup de nos familles compter sur le
système scolaire public dit elle au dos
qui tue ses enfants sont maintenant à la
maison le meilleur julien kangaroo nov
normal les plats sont là dit il venez
vous servir il n'y a pas d'inscription
pas de surveillance
draghi à tanger pas d'horaires non plus
et c'est ce qui plaît attalib winehouse
s'est tous les autres ont des heures
fixes populaire ça peut nourrir une
famille dit il
ce ne sont pas juste des pommes de terre
et des oignons aux experts le matin et
c'est nutritifs et sur chaque
réfrigérateur il est inscrit par ce que
vous comptez que vous êtes l'avenir que
vous travaillez fort parce que nous
tenons à vous des mots d'encouragement
pour les clients anonymes
en cette période difficile
[Musique]